faute de conducteurs 19 trains sont
supprimés chaque jour sur le est reversé
depuis le 5 septembre
que ce soit en heures de pointe ou en
heures creuses des perturbations que les
usagers déjà remarqué à wind
5348 spontanément supprimés même après
avoir consulté des sites et les trains
étant affichée arrivant à la gare c'est
très gênant de ne plus pouvoir partir
notamment le matin quand un autre chose
à faire après ça fait des années et des
années de neige d'utiliser des années
que c'est c'est du n'importe quoi des
années qu'on nous prétendus travaux des
fermetures acceptera pas de
correspondance des cas enfin bon il ya
plein de choses qui font que la ligne c
est la plus longue d'île de france elle
traverse sept départements dont les
yvelines et s'étend sur 187 km c'est
environ 500 mille passagers qui sont
concernés par ces suppressions qui vont
devoir se lever une demi-heure une heure
plus tôt pour pouvoir aller au travail
sur paris qui vont devoir rentrer plus
tard le soir chez eux c'est une casse
jamais vu du service public en île de
france si ces trains sont supprimés
c'est à cause d'un manque de conducteurs
la sncf reconnaît qu'à à des difficultés
de recrutement depuis deux ans une
situation due en partie aux copies de 19
qui a été mal anticipée selon la cgt des
cheminots que les écoles de conducteurs
ont été fermés pendant le confinement
mais elles ont réouverte depuis 1 depuis
déjà 2 de fin 2020 donc on aurait pu
engager une politique de recrutement
beaucoup plus importante la vérité c'est
qu'il y a un agenda caché de la
direction sait qu'on va avoir
l'ouverture du train massy evry du
tram-train en 2024 donc la direction se
dit je vais avoir besoin de moins de
conducteurs de demain il va y avoir
aussi l'agenda des privatisations la
direction se dit il va y avoir moins de
charge et en 2022 la sncf s'est fixé
comme objectif de recruter 200 cheminots